あの大乗仏教だとよく般若心経とかありますよね
般若波羅蜜っていうのをすごく言いますね
あれはテーラワーダとか
テーラワーダでいうプラクジャーパーミタあります
これは知恵の完成でジャータカあります
じゃあプラクジャの場合はジャータカたくさんあります
私は思い出してるのは分厚いジャータカ物語だからね
まあ小さいものっていうのは思い出せませんね
ジャータカテキストのこの最後のところで
長い長いジャータカ物語2つあります
一つはプラクジャを完成したものと
もう一つは今言ったヴェッサンタラジャータカ物語という
あの お布施のそれで終了しました
あのテキストは そちら知恵ですね
知恵のものっていうのは
結構あります 仏教でいうパンニャーとプラクニャーっていうのは理性なんです
だからこの長いジャータカの小さなエピソード
一部たくさんありまして
どれ一つ一つを説明 いくつか思い出した
思い出せば全部思い出しますから
この厚い本なんで 私は読んだ時でもこれぐらいのもうシンハラ語でもありますからね
2 3 日間かかります 全部読もうとしたら
ある菩薩がなんか天才的な能力を持ってどこか村に生まれる
そこで王様にはものすごい抜群の頭のいいアドバイザーが 4人がいる
そこでこの菩薩はすごい田舎で百姓さんの家で
何も財産ないところで生まれるんです
生まれてでもいきなり国の特別な前兆が現れちゃったんです
王様がなんでこういうなんか変な前兆が現れたんだと
どういうことかと この占い
あの4人のアドバイザーに聞くんで
彼らがアドバイスして
占ってみて 王様の国で想像を絶する知恵のある人が生まれたんだと
子供が そういう前兆やと言ったら
調べてどこに生まれたかと調べたら
王様がすぐだったら赤ちゃんの時
私がもらった方がいいやと
こんな宝物だったら言ったら
この4人がもうちょっとからくりする
あの いくらなんでもあの人の知恵
知識 知恵には 我々のはもう値しないんだと
立場がなくなります ですから
なんとかしてやめさせましょうと
ただ  赤ちゃんだからね
王様取り出しには行きませんよと
もっと大きくなったら
ことで中止にさせる そこで子供はどんどん大きくなる
それで遊び盛りの年になる
その時は その子はどんな問題があっても解決してあげる
その地方で村で それでちっちゃな時でも
子供の間で問題あったらもう解決してあげたりして
で まあいろいろたくさんあります
えーと そこで王様 それで子供が小さいのに
自分が人間の問題解決するんだから
村人をみんな集めて まあこれは大変なことで
もうなんとかしなくちゃということで
小さなこの行動を作るんです
みんなでボランティアで向道を作って
この子供に君がここで審判しなさいと
そこで何か問題あったらそちらに
子供はそこでちゃんと解決してあげる
と で 一つはこのヨーロッパでも知られている物語で
この鬼とか まあ子供の話でね
あるお母さんが子供を産まれて
で 鬼がこれを見て食べたくて女に変身して
ああ 可愛い子ですね おっぱいあげてもいいんでしょうかということで
まあいいでしょうと言ったら
おっぱいあげたりして
これで子供連れて逃げたりする
それで逃げると もうもう鬼の女が足が速いし
実の母親は普通人間だから
もうどうしようもない
そこでこの子供が遊んでいる遊び場を通っていくと
もうものすごい大騒ぎ
私の子供を返せと この女はもう何言うんですか？私の子供を
と鬼が言う で 村人たちも見たら
もうどうしようもないし
私の女返せと女が走っているはずもないし
もうとにかく二人とも捕まったんです
捕まってもう話にならないだから菩薩のところに連れて行って
菩薩見ただけで こんなでっかい態度で人間見てない
びくともしないのはね
これがおそらく人間でないとまず知ってるんですよ
というのは いくらなんでも怯えたりしますよと
それでちらちらと下を見たら
もう影はないんだと まあ向こうの
いわゆる鬼には影がないということで
変身したものに はあ これが
まあでもそれ言ったっても裁判にはなりません
あんた鬼でしょうと それは裁判になりません
それで裁判は理性的に行うのです
それでいろいろ聞いても
もう質問すると鬼の方が勝ちますね
で じゃあしょうがないということで
線を引いて じゃあ好きなと子供って子供をそっちに置いておいて引いてみてくださいと
引いてもらった人の子供にしますと
言うと まあどちらに取りますかと言っちゃうと
鬼の方が足の方 じゃなくて手の方を取るんですね
お母さんは足の方取っちゃうんです
足で引っ張ってても 子供の痛くもかゆくもないんだからね
それではい 引いてくださいと言った途端
鬼がもう食べたいんだからね
ちょっと引くんですよ
手で それとお母さんには言ってもったいらない
すぐもう手を外しちゃう
ったら鬼が ほら 私の子供だよ
裁判だ 判決はそれでしょうと
したら菩薩はちょっと待ってくださいと
また調べることはありますよ
あなたね なんで子供を外したんですかと
ったら そんなことできるんで
子供痛いでしょうねと
怪我でもしたらどうしますかと
あなた方はと で 向こうは反論するんですね
で 菩薩はみんなに聞くんです
子供のことを心配するのは産んだ人ですか？他の人ですか？と
これは産んだ人です では
この二人で誰が心配しているんでしょうか
やっぱり負けた人はそうですよと
だからあなた子供がいます
で そういう人は終わっちゃうんですね
そういう人をたくさんまとめています
もう一つ この夫婦の間も同じことになっちゃって
ある女の人がもう他の男に気に入られちゃって
その男と逃げる 旦那が追っかけていて
それでまた菩薩のところに連れて行く
これ私の家内でしょうと女も言う
私はこのこの人知りませんよとかね
この人のあれやとかね
それか判決しなくちゃいけない
難しいんですよ それで菩薩は 3人とあっちあっちこっち一人一人で
男一人呼んで お前の名前
生年月日 お前の家名の名前
生年月日 聞いてはい 出て行きなさい
次の男来なさい お前の名前
生年月日 それからお前の家名の名前と生年月日
それで聞く はい 出て行きなさい
で 女を呼ぶ お前の名前
生年月日は でお前の旦那の名前
生年月日はその場合はこの本当の男は自分の奥さんの名前
生年月日を知っているんですよ
それを正しく言ったんです
それでインチキの男は自分の名前
生年月日は当たり前だから
奥さんの名前は聞いてないんです
生年月日は知らないんで
だからなんとか言ったんです
そこで女に聞いてみれば
女は自分の名前 生年月日を当然知っている
しかし 自分がこれから出ていこうとしている男の名前
生年月日を知らないんですね
なんとか言ったんです
それですぐバレるでしょ
それでみんなの聞いてください
調べてくださいと 誰がちゃんと知っているのか
そうすると 女の名前 生年月日を正しく言った男は本当の旦那であると
それで完結する まあそういうふうな
もうこれ 知恵のジャータカなんで
これはあの大きなジャータコの中で
このものすごいぐらい小さなエピソードたくさんあります
その小さなエピソードの中で一つなんです
そういうことで このプラグナーパーリミターという般若っていうのは
ジャータパーリミターの中で一つで
それはただの理性 知識を育てるということで
それで知恵を完成するんです
それであの政治論の場合はね
いっぱいありまして それはパーリみたいに関係ないんですけど
もう一つ 政治論の物語があります
持ってきたんだから言いますけど
ある王様がいて 王様に子供がないんですね
全然女の子も男もどうか生まれてこないんです
そこで公園に遊びに行ったある日
昼寝して目を覚めたら
この木の下上で鳥の巣が見たんですね
鳥の巣を見たら なんかすごくほほえましくなっちゃったんですね
子供だから いくらなんでも
いいなと こちらに子供がいて
ので 誰かに家来へね もう登ってこの調べてくださいと言ったら
登った人はこの卵を 3つ見つけて
だから王様はすごく気をつけて気をつけてということで
ものすごい柔らかい綿で
この卵をもらって 卵見ただけで
これは３人と私の子供にするそうと決めて
卵 これどんな鳥でしょうか？と聞いたらわからないんですね
誰も そうすると この狩り
森の中で生活する狩り
狩り人の人々いるんだから
その責任で呼んで卵を調べさせたんです
ったら王様  1個の卵はフクロウの卵ですと
もう１個はは何でしたっけ？九官鳥の卵
もう１個はオウムの卵です
あれと ああ まあそんなこともありえますよと言ったら
もう王様がこの３人と私の子供ですということで
大臣３人に任せてあげたんで
ちゃんとこれを温めてあげてください
それでもうちゃんと鳥
まあ最初にあのフクロウが出て
それからもう何でしたっけ？九官鳥も生まれて
雛が生まれて雛が生まれる
雛が生まれたということで
はあ 子供が生まれる 王様が喜ぶんですね
それで大臣たちにいろいろ
もう私の子供のように面倒見なさいと
私の子供やと それで大きくなるんで
各大臣の家で あまりにも王様が私の子供
私のことを言うんだからね
大臣対王様のことを馬鹿にするんですね
結構イカれてるんだと
それは王様もなんかニコニコと笑っちゃうのは見てね
なんか私は馬鹿にしてるみたい
しかし王様は本気なんですね
そこから論理的には一応成り立ちませんだけど
王様はなんかけなしてるの見てね
あなた方はね 私の子供たちがね
鳥だと思って馬鹿にしてるでしょうに
見せてやるぞと 馬鹿にできるかということで連絡して
もうまず第一 フクロウの先に生まれたんだからね
私はそれから女の子か男か
また調べて名前をつけるんですよ
フクロウは男の子で 九官鳥は女の子で
オウムまた男の子なんですね
で それなりに名前をつけちゃって
息子に会いに行きますよと連絡して
それでフクロウは私の父親が来るんだからね
ちゃんと用意しなさいよと何とか言ったりして
それで王様会ったらなんかフクロウ怒るんですね
なんで今更ですかね 思い出したのは我々のことはとかね
それでとにかくあの王様が私はどのように政治するべきかとアドバイスを受けるんですよ
みんなの前で 教えてください
そうするとフクロウはちゃんと王たる者はこういうふうに政治するべきとアドバイスする
ね 約あったことはあるの
この怒るフクロウというのは怒らない
いかなる場合でも怒らないことと
あの何かあっても嘘をつかない
というか 真理を守ってすることと
それからこのふざけちゃいかん
王はいつでも真剣にならなくちゃいけないんだよ
長いんですよ これは選びたくなかったんですけど
芸はもうもう以上あります
もう一個一個  それで王様はもうよくわかりましたと
次の日 またある日 また次の鳥のところに行って
あの九官鳥 九官鳥からもいろいろ教えてもらって
それから最後にオウムの息子のところに行ったら
オウムはもうしっかり最後の説法するんですよ
もう王としてどうすればいいかと
そちらでは芸はわかりやすくて
この王たる者は法によって政治するんだよと
法によって自分の親戚
友人 信頼の人々は守るんだ
法によって国民を守るのだ
法によって政治するのだ
法によって動植物まで守るのだという
このダンマですね 真理に基づいてやりなさいと
すごい長い説法をするんです
で 王様はみんなにね 鳥だと馬鹿にするんじゃないんだよという話で終わります
が そこでこのヒューマン的に
言いたがっているのは何でしょうかね
やっぱり馬鹿にしてはいけないということなんです
学ぶべきものは動物からでも学べます
時々忍耐 相手のことを心配する
献身的になること 動物を見てください
持ってますよ ものすごい
だからただの動物ではないこと
神様は魂を吹き込んでないんではないかとか
そんなことじゃないんですよ
本当にそれぞれの動物
それぞれ性格を持っても
人間が驚くほどすごい立派な性格を持っている動物もいます
だから学べということで
もう一つ言いたいところは
いい加減でわがままで政治する王っていうのは動物より以下だよということでもあります
政治家が自分の懐を増やすことしか肥やすことしか考えていないならば
まあ拝むものじゃなくて
動物より以下やということを言っているんですね
だから厳しいんですよ
その点ではやわらかくなかった
そのように  それはただの政治論だから
菩薩はそれで何を学んだかとわかりませんだけど
だからそういうのは一寸で一人かもしれませんだけど
菩薩は自分の人格は一人一人でもうすごいことを経験しながら学んではいきました
そういうことで 一応もう時間は 6時半になりそうです
今日は質問なしに終わります
はい まあストーリーはもう話は先に終わりましたからね
ストーリーはただ単にストーリー
例を出しながらは喋れません
今日のポイントとしては
この経験ということ 経験はずっと得なくちゃいけない
一生見習いであること
あるべきであること それから何事も真剣に
いい加減は絶対ダメと
どんなつまらないことでも
ちゃんと真剣にやらなくちゃいかないんです
そうすると誰でも経験を得る場を与えてくれます
いい加減だったら経験得たくても得られなくなります
そういうところなんです
覚えてほしいところは
はい どうもありがとうございます
どうしますか？これから
では  ありがとうございます
では はい  この法蔵の三宝に礼拝敬し
最後の法に息の瞑想とヴィパッサナー修行によって積まれた功徳を
神々 先祖 祖父母 両親 親族
恩師をはじめとし 一切の生きとし生けるものに回向いたします
この功徳によって すべての生きとし生けるものが幸福に暮らせますように
そして解脱を得られますように
サッビーティヨー ヴィパッジャントー サッバローゴー ヴィナッサトゥ マーテー バワットワンタラーヨー スッキー
ディーガー ユコー バワー バウトゥ サッバ マンガラーン ラッカントゥ サッバデーヴァター サッバ ブッダヌ
バーヴェーナ サッバ ダンマーヌバーヴェーナ サッバ サンガーヌバーヴェーナ サダー スッティ
バワントゥ テー アビワダナシーリッサ ニッチャン ワッダー パチャヤーイナ チャッターロ ダンマ ワッダンティ ヤーユ ワンノー スカン バラン
それではどうもありがとうございます
ありがとうございます